I'm pleased that I am able to meet
President Trump so early in his
administration that is a sign of the
strength of the special relationship
between the United Kingdom and the
United States of America on special a
special relationship on which he and I
intend to build but can I also say to
the leader of the Opposition I am not
afraid to speak frankly to a President
of the United States I am able to do
that because we have that special
relationship a special relationship that
he would never have with the United
States Mr Speaker we would never allow
Britain to be sold up on the cheap how
confident is she of getting a good deal
for global Britain from a president who
wants to put America first by American
and build a wall between his country and
Mexico mrs. article 50 wasn't about a
court judgment against this government
what it signified was the bad judgment
of this government the bad judgment of
prioritizing
corporate tax cuts over investment in
National Health and Social Care the bad
judgment of threatening European
partners whilst offering a blank check
to President Trump
the bad judgement of wanting to turn
Britain into a bargain-basement tax
haven so will she offer some clarity and
some certainty and withdraw the threats
to destroy the social structure of this
country by turning us into the bargain
basement
she clearly threatens Prime Minister we
will be out around the world with the EU
America and other countries negotiating
good free trade deals for this country
though will bring prosperity to this
country but the right honourable
gentleman wants to talk about brexit I
have to say to him he's a leader of the
party he can't even agree with his
shadow Chancellor about brexit the
Shadow Chancellor can't agree with the
shadow brexit secretary the shadow
bricks its secretary disagrees with the
shadow home secretary and the shadow
home secretary ring up the leader and
tell him to change his mind
he talks about us standing up for
Britain they can't speak to themselves
they'll never speak for Britain
you